the taliban has captured its eighth
provincial capital in afghanistan this
time in the city of pali khumri the
capital of baghlan province which is
just north of kabul
earlier fighters overran the city of
farah in the south west after a fierce
gun battle afghan forces also battling
the taliban to save the provinces of
helmand kandahar and harat but they are
struggling to stop the armed groups
rapid advance as u.s troops complete
their pull out by the end of this month
let's get more from rob mcbride now who
joins us live on the phone from kabul so
robert worrying another worrying
development this uh for the afghan
government forces giving this particular
city is is quite close to uh kabul
that's right this is a blow for the
afghan government it is as you say it is
the eighth province now to fall uh in uh
a short number of days there has been
fighting in this province for the past
couple of days uh and the uh security
forces in poly cumbria have come under
pressure uh and it was claimed earlier
by the taliban that they'd forced these
security forces out that has now been
confirmed to us that in fact this has
become the latest provincial capital to
fall to the taliban it is one of the uh
the less important provincial capitals
uh
there have been a number of smaller
cities that have fallen it is it's still
in this uh northern swathe of the
countryside that has seen a lot of the
fighting but nonetheless it does bring
that fighting closer to kabul and that
must be the concern for of the
government uh that we have seen so much
uh fighting really across the whole uh
the whole of afghanistan uh in the past
week or so in fact around half of all of
the provinces are reporting some sort of
conflict or clashes
of different degrees so this is the
latest uh province to fall as far as the
government is concerned its priority now
is to concentrate on some of the more
important provincial centers uh such as
mazari sharif and herac
centers that it does certainly still
have control of and put its resources
there it says it does have plans to
retake some of these lesser provinces
but given the pace of the advanced by
the taliban it remains to be seen if
it's going to put those counter-affect
those counter-attacks into effect uh and
if indeed they will be successful
rob thanks for that update rob mcbride
there on the line from kabul for us well
the setback for the afghan government
comes just hours after emergency talks
began here in doha to stop the violence
the top u.s diplomat for afghanistan is
in the
qatari capital for those discussions
we'll
have
the latest on the fighting in a moment
but first let's go to muhammad jamjum in
dalha for more
on those talks muhammad what do you know
well hasim the talks have officially
ended for this the first day of these
emergency talks here in doha
just in the past 45 minutes or so
we saw u.s special envoy for
afghanistan's al-meghalzad
as well as members of the taliban
delegation leaving the conference center
just behind us here at this venue they
did not make any remarks to the
assembled press and that's really been a
theme throughout the day many of the
diplomats here just not speaking on the
record or on camera throughout the day
really waiting to see what happens as a
result of these talks there is a great
push here by many international actors
uh throughout the day you've had the
envoys from qatar from the uk u.n eu
china pakistan and uzbekistan as well of
course as the u.s they've been here they
met first with a delegation from afghans
from the afghanistan government led by
dr abdullah abdullah head of the
national reconciliation council of
afghanistan um that meeting lasted just
about an hour and a half and then a
couple of hours after that you had a
much longer meeting uh which was was
between these envoys that are here and
the members of the taliban delegation
again unclear what exactly was said
during those meetings but if you take a
step back and look at a statement that
was issued by u.s special envoy
envoy
khalilzad earlier today he said the
following he said in several planned
rounds of meetings over three days
representatives from countries in the
region and beyond as well as from
multilateral organizations will press
for a reduction of violence and
ceasefire and a commitment not to
recognize a government imposed by force
so it certainly seems to indicate that
one of the messages that was perhaps
conveyed to members of the taliban
delegation would have been that the
international actors assembled here are
not going to
recognize any government in afghanistan
that is seized by force seized by the
taliban by force
where exactly this leads to next is
anybody's guess one of the things that
the diplomats that are assembled here
would like to see happen is they would
like to see the intra-afghan dialogue
the inter-afghan peace process which has
been playing out here in doha since last
september the last meeting of which
happened in mid-july they'd like to see
that get back on track
some have suggested throughout the day
that perhaps maybe an announcement could
be made before the end of these meetings
that another intra-afghan peace talk
session might happen but again that's
all just speculation at this point
really what these international actors
want to see happen is they want to come
up with some sort of joint plan to try
to get things back on track in
afghanistan to try to come up with some
sort of joint plan to respond to a very
rapidly deteriorating situation in
afghanistan hazard all right for the
moment uh muhammad jam jum lifers there
in darha thanks mohammed
now the european union says about 400
000 afghans have been internally
displaced by the fighting in recent
months as more provincial capitals fall
to the taliban thousands have fled to
kabul but as charlotte bellis reports
from the afghan capital they have
arrived to find little support
thousands of people have arrived at this
kabul park the majority have come from
northern afghanistan predominantly the
provinces of taha and kunduz both of
which their provincial capitals fell to
the taliban over the weekend people here
tell us that they were bombarded with
airstrikes there was constant gunfire
and they struggled to find a way out
they were firing one bullet but the
government forces were firing hundreds
of them over our heads then i said to my
wife let's leave everything and just run
our area is destroyed people were
running past dead bodies and not
stopping
people here have told us it was a real
challenge even just to reach kabul they
really struggled to find transport to
get them from the north they had to take
the seats out of buses to pack more
people in they said it took them about
10 to 12 hours to reach kabul and that
they had to cross through badland where
there is a big battle between the
government and taliban
when i was leaving the city i noticed
the families were gone from their homes
they locked their doors there were women
on the streets running and there were
lots of airstrikes i saw one woman who
was hit and injured maybe with a mortar
when i saw that i cried for hours
when the taliban came they looted
everything they burned our houses we
just ran we left our clothes and left
our front door open and just ran
now we live in this tents please help us
the government is offering some handouts
people in kabul are offering donations
also but as you can see there is very
little support shelter food or aid for
the people arriving here now the un says
this situation is not unique they say
that in the first week of august they
have counted 70 000 people who have fled
their homes due to conflict and are in
need of their support they also say 30
000 people are fleeing the country every
week charlotte ballas al jazeera kabul